[Music]
listen I mentioned Nerdist industries
you are really you are a spokesman for
nerds no don't say that I get old when
people say that I am NOT a spokesman for
nerds I just like nerdy things and that
is my cousin ERDs love to tell you why
you suck and I don't so you're saying
that when you and when anyone thinks
that you've proclaimed yourself a
spokesman for nerd which I've not done
all right clear that nerds go online and
they go after you it's like right we'll
see about that yeah and the problem is I
do control the lot but you know it's
kind of funny cuz like I used to get my
ass kicked by Jackson grade school -
then grow up and get bullied by nerds on
the internet so it seems unfair but I
understand it because it used to really
hurt my feelings and then one day I
noticed myself in the mirror as I often
do and I was like oh I look like a
douchebag that's why I look like a
douche like a skinny jean strategically
messed up hair like I have a soft Bill
Nye Center but a crunchy Seacrest outer
shell it's like screw that guy he looks
like a douche bag so I get it I totally
understand wait a minute okay I think
you've been a little hard on yourself in
the looks department but I will say you
you live the life you do you walk the
walk you don't just talk the talk we
found out this is a photo in your
bedroom you have a doctor who door
that's the car this is this this isn't
your none of your bedroom it's in your
house my house you have your real what
does it adopt a TARDIS it means time and
relative dimension in space here
together I put that in there's a room in
my house that looks like an old log
cabin and so I put I had a TARDIS built
and when you actually it has a remote
control so it goes
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
gratulations I show you have too much
money won't some willing young lady
accept my seed by the way I am totally
single by the way so that should be no
surprise though now that that TARDIS
door is out well the thing is the TARDIS
is actually a door to a fitness room
well sure it's not it totally is when
you go to your you have a gym I put a
gym in the house to say listen I'm sorry
a fitness room but you when you go to
the gym you push a button and friend the
TARDIS for those moves and opens up well
I made it the the fitness room because
and again now I'm starting to drift into
douchebag territory but the problem is I
used to be like a doughy video game
addict guy and I just got tired of being
unemployed in masturbation so I decided
to like focus all those resources on
trying to get you lost me at tired of
masturbation well this got old
time to build ships in a bottle yeah I'm
so tired of you what's your natural no
all right you know we're gonna do we're
gonna take a little break
okay okay you'll hear when we come back
not Glenn you're gonna go to another
dimension
you know we will be right back much more
Chris Hardwick after this the ground
[Applause]
you